trois mille kilomètres c'est la distance
que parcourt en moyenne un produit avant
d'arriver à son point de chute
un coup dur pour l'environnement mais
aussi pour l'agriculture locale pour y
faire face un nouveau modèle prend de
l'ampleur celui des circuits courts
illustration dans ce village de 4600
habitants selles sur cher où se rend
tous les jeudis et guillaume séchet 32
ans producteur dove de pâturage vous
revenez la semaine prochaine ça marche
merci voit bien que l'agriculture
française à peine à valoriser ses
produits il ya des systèmes qui sont en
route depuis longtemps qui font de la
quantité
malheureusement ben c'est très fragile
quoi alors qu'en étant plus petit on
maîtrise beaucoup mieux sa vie parce que
si je m'étais installé
dans ce domaine là par exemple à faire
l'industriel à faire du chiffre
je me serais débarrasser un petit peu de
deux de ma production au détriment de la
qualité
voilà là je fais un peu plus de qualité
plus petite échelle
et puis d'essayer d'être d'être autonome
et puis depuis de pouvoir avoir une
vision sur l'avenir
et voilà merci vous aussi bonjour on va
manger frais bio et local et les clients
sont de plus en plus friands quitte à
mettre la main au porte-monnaie pour
trouver des bons produits et un plutôt
que dans les supermarchés quoi voilà
et puis c'est le sondé comment comme on
dit des produits locaux et pour les
producteurs locaux faire travailler les
gens quand même voilà
quitte à payer un peu plus cher je m'en
fiche je veux de la qualité
et puis les produits frais c'est quand
même meilleur que les conserves et tout
le reste c'est pour ça que je j'achète
beaucoup marché pour les connaissez des
commerçants qu'on connaît depuis
longtemps on sait que ces frais que ces
garanties à une garantie qu'on mange
mieux
donc on retrouve un bienfait et
l'argent qu'on met dans la nourriture
mais pendant les médicaments guillaume
séchet ce n'est pas le seul agriculteur
de la région favoriser les circuits
courts à montmorillon et c'est tout un
marché bio et local qui a ouvert ses
portes en 2014
quatre demi journées par semaine il
propose les produits d'une quarantaine
d'agriculteurs locaux
le fait de vendre en direct ça a réduit
les commissions qui sont prises par les
grossistes et semi-grossistes enfin et
du coup les
les producteurs vendent au prix de leur
travail et le consommateur lui en
échange il a un prix qui est équitable
pour lui aussi parce qu'effectivement le
producteur va pas
rajouter sur son prix de vente les
marches que pourrait lui prendre une
grande distribution
par ailleurs on est soucieux du
kilométrage du carburant etc voilà est
derrière soucieux d'abord de la
production de la qualité la production
là on a deux gammes on a du bio et du
non bio mais le non bio il sera tracé un
il sera sans s'en produit mais sans
appellation bio on consomme peut-être un
peu moins et de meilleure qualité
voilà là je pense que la majoritairement
maintenant les gens ils en ont marre des
produits chimiques des quelque chose des
listes comme ça sur chaque produit
donc ça il ya vraiment une éducation qui
est en train de se faire avec
génération les médias je pense que les
gens sont sensibles à ça moi c'est
important de savoir
j'aime bien savoir ce que je mange donc
les produits soient sains c'est pour moi
c'est indispensable pour mon équilibre
vous l'aurez compris les circuits courts
agricoles connaissent envie succès ici
dans la région
il assure en effet la préservation de
l'environnement la juste rémunération
des producteurs et la qualité nutritive
des aliments du gagnant gagnant en somme
autant pour le producteur que le
consommateur